on est devant le portail qui n'ouvrent
pas la télécommande marche plus
visiblement vous répondez pas votre
téléphone
c'est notre maison non pour l'instant
ils sont chez eux
il a signé un contrat non mais quel
contrat soyez raisonnable et partez
maintenant sinon quoi l'audience aura
lieu le 9 novembre c'est la trêve
hivernale on va payer les traites de
leur maison pour loger deux squatteurs
pendant qu'on vivra dans une caravane
avec toi tu vis en vacances pas vraiment
green way on t'écoute
si vous faites voler si vous êtes un
faible je pense que tu es une victime
parce que tu as décidé de l'être dit que
c'est chez toi c'est chez moi c'est chez
toi rouler quand on aura un problème on
sera bien obligé de le régler tout seul
cette société part en couille
[Musique]
ne fut pas la peur savoure là
embrasse là c'est quoi le plan
[Musique]